you know i have perfect pitch so i can
tell but if you play something that's a
f
[Music]
that's supposed to be f
e uh
but e is really
yeah vibrating hi i'm john batiste and
i'm a guest correspondent for wired
and today i'll be testing and reviewing
music tech
[Music]
first gadget
i love this this look like the 1950s i
love the vibe of it it has this built-in
speaker system looking thing
stylophone retro pocket synth each
segment on the surface plays a different
note the same as different keys on a
piano
you can switch between three sound modes
and make the sound wobble with the
vibrato switch oh fire amazon customer
gave it five stars inside of a cheap
micro controller there was an actual
circuit board with a chain of resistors
and a five five five timer this was an
unexpected surprise and gives the
instrument a much better feeling of
authenticity
but
i'm a little bit suspicious of that
because it says amazon customer it's not
a it's not a name i think that might be
a audience plant as we say in the
business
[Music]
and this is a bad review from s anderson
cheap garbage
90 of the time when i turn it on it just
makes some low frequency croaks and
creaks and then goes silent that's
actually kind of dope let's see what we
got
oh
hear that song
[Music]
i've used this on the album this fire
that's supposed to be f e uh
but e is really
yeah vibrating it's like micro tones off
from what's actually e
a440 frequency of a4 i know he just
alienated most of the viewers but
that's my review of this thing
i love odd stuff like this that's small
that you can fit in your pocket i give
it five stars i love it but you know
it's a little out of pitch next gadget
please
[Music]
oh first impressions actually oh wow
hear that that's nice it's kind of like
twister for fingers and cell phone
addiction
sphero spec drums also known as finger
drums sphero spec drums are app-enabled
music rings that make the world your
instrument by turning colors into sounds
turning colors into sounds
that's soulful these are reviews for the
spec drums finger drums they work by
recognizing color so they will work on
just about anything which really makes
for fun five star review oh there's
another review here but it's a bad
review it has an issue with the
bluetooth pairing and as there's no way
to reset the code or enter a code it's
pretty much useless see ballard well
let's see how it works for me
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
that's killer
y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like the difference between making
something from scratch or
you buy ingredients
of varying degrees of preparation how
you put it together ultimately there's
an artistry in that
so i give it
you know five stars for what it is
yeah where the next gadget at let's get
it
oh
[Applause]
i love this this killing if it ain't fun
i don't want none
ah play 22 keyboard also known as the
floor piano also known as the iconic
instrumentation from the movie big
[Laughter]
gigantic electronic keyboard play mat
super strong vinyl mat comes with eight
musical instruments piano saxophone
violin clarinet trumpet banjo xylophone
guitar five star review
absolutely perfect my two-year-old
granddaughter loves it it's large enough
for her to run across and very durable
one star review
garbage bag plastic construction and
garbage sound
it got that kid thing ha ha that kid
vibe
wait a minute
that
these are not the right pictures
okay so it's a half step off
[Music]
man
this
is very ineffective
this probably cost
fifty dollars 37
okay okay
[Music]
i would say the pitch not being
right on
very far off in fact the half step off
but then the the record and playback
function gives it some points so i give
it three stars somewhere in there
oh my goodness to the soles of my feet i
am blessed this looks like a
tone
manipulation device for acoustic guitar
tone wood amp similar to the way the
strings excite the top of the guitar to
produce sound tonewood amp excites the
back of the instrument producing sound
waves of effects such as reverb echo
delay tremolo and more so let's see
pastor jerry roane
on amazon five-star review within 10
minutes it sounds great and the folks i
play for love the added effects of my
acoustic guitar now i'm gonna add the
chorus effect can't wait pastor jerry
rome oh come on pastor
[Music]
oh
sometimes i open my mind
and i
dream
[Music]
tremolo
this is really great with no amp and
everything like that
[Music]
delay
it makes me feel like i'm in the
wilderness
okay so for me
as a performer who has busked before and
played on the
different
forms of public transit
i find this to be a great device it
gives you a
added production value at a very minimal
real estate very small compact device
here i think it opens the imagination
it's a great advancement in technology
five stars
oh yeah
oh yeah i know about this
it has a plastic base i like the color
it feels retro 70s energy just something
that you might have seen or heard at a
doors concert
andy's recorder keyboard also known as
melodica this unique instrument
looks like a keyboard but sounds like a
recorder five-star review always been
intrigued by this quirky keyboard
portable and breadth-powered it's unique
and great for busking and now we got a
three-star review the quality
deteriorates as you approach the higher
register so he's probably saying that
the the quality of the high register is
not
okay
i can't hear what he's saying with that
my normal melodica has a lot more of a
sturdy tone it holds the air
with much more authority in this as soon
as the air hits the read
you're almost done with the resonance of
the pitch whereas on my melodic i could
blow and i can buzz or i can kind of um
press the air slowly and i can even bend
the notes here you really have
only a few options with the pitch
because of how the airstream is
constructed
i love how it's just inconsistent it's
like a very mom and pop do-it-yourself
kind of instrument it's like i built
this at home in my wood shop the top
part don't really work that well in the
bottom you got to kind of like blow a
little harder to get the sound and in
the middle you know sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't but the charm of
that is what i like about it actually
five stars
hey
tech
technopolis i like some of them i liked
all of them for what they are be who you
are be you see you next time
[Music]